[Music]
all right at his Tennessee rally tonight
in support of Senate candidate Marsha
Blackburn President Trump went after
Blackburn's opponent Democratic
leadership this is great stuff what's
this
he's an absolute total tool of Chuck of
Chuck Schumer he's a tool of Chuck
Schumer and of course the ms-13 lover
Nancy Pelosi I said they're animals and
she said how dare you say that how dare
you say that have you seen what they've
done have you seen what they're doing to
us and we're taking them out of our
country by the thousands out joining us
now former deputy assistant to the
president Fox News national security
strategist dr. korkor NRA TV contributor
former Secret Service agent Dan bond
Geno dr. korkor the election I think is
the biggest most important midterm it'll
be about taking back the tax cuts it
will be about impeaching this president
and undoing an election and it'll be
about a lot of the other things the
president mentioned tonight he talked a
lot about the election tonight was a
bond storm I just started ticking off
the things he covered and I just ran out
of space Sean whether it's you know
Nancy the ms-13 lover whether it's
standing up for the flag whether it's
the Second Amendment rebuilding our
military the tax cuts on this this this
was the speech you don't need any
talking points for November I don't care
who the candidate is whether it's the
Senate it's the house this is the speech
that nailed the you know the the the
Republican wave not the Democrat wave
and I'm not gonna say blue wave because
guess who's color is blue it's our color
if there's any party that's red it's the
Democrats so tonight was spectacular and
I don't see what the Democrats have to
run on after tonight bringing back Isis
raising your taxes letting more ms-13
into the country tonight was fabulous
Shawn what's your take down I think it I
think this midterm election is the
biggest
in our lifetime because knowing what
they want to do that they're saying to
each other yeah we want to do it but
don't tell the American people it's like
a big lie to the American people yeah
you're right Shawn listen if we lose the
house this president will be impeached
for nothing he'll be impeached because
he won an election there will be no
serious crimes and misdemeanors but I
thought the line of the night was the
ms-13 line again a gift of Donald Trump
said this is the gift of Donald Trump
right Donald Trump gets the Democrats to
show their butts to the American people
all the time it's show them who they
really are
he gets him to defend ms-13 Hamas and
the North Koreans all in the span of the
last month that's your Democrats that's
who they really are
nice job president Trump he's the only
one that could have done that it's so
true and it's like they own the media
the Sheep that they are oh it's like a
breakup letter
well the breakup letter got and within
24 hours Kim jong-un's people pretty
please
little rocket man begging to meet with
the president it's it's a it's a classic
example part of the deal all right thank
you both we got a short night tonight
because